on this one little tangent that you
brought up
this is almost an outdated idea but it's
still with us which is
cryptocurrencies are used for illegal
activity for drugs for crime
and so on is there some sense
that worries you that if uh
if cryptocurrency if ethereum runs the
world
then crime making money from crime will
be easier
there's always that possibility like at
the same time i think if you look at you
know
the world as a whole and like the way
all the other technological trends are
going like
you know in-person surveillance is just
going up every year right
yeah like the if you commit a crime in
you know meat space it's getting harder
and harder to get away with it
uh so like you know if he wants to do
something
and and this is something that's just
like happening as a result of you know
just
better technology information and
information transparency like
a lot of it's hard to prevent even if
you really tried
um so i the world
where like things go dark to such an ex
you know as the the one the police hawks
sometimes like to say
um to such an extent that like you know
oh my god the criminals are committing
crimes with impunity and we can't
see anything like that just seems
unlikely um but
you know on the other hand like uh the
world uh
where there just you know
is no privacy for example or um
the world where there just like is no
no ability to kind of act outside of the
the confines of you know mainstream
institutions like that's uh
some that's something that's more
realistic and that seems like
something that could lead to a lot of
kind of
a lot of scary things right and like
even from a government's point of view
right like i think
governments over the last few years a
lot of them they're very worried about
sovereignty you know they're worried
about like if
their um country's economy
and you know social environments they're
just completely dependent on basically
foreign tech companies
controlled by foreign governments like
you know governments are not on team
government right it's like you know
the indian government is on you know
team india
you know the russian government is on
team russia and so forth right so
like you know they don't want the us to
be able to like have this big backdoor
into everything
uh so i mean i do think that a balance
is needed but
at the same time i uh do
and think um i guess i
i definitely like worry more
about the messiah the possibility that
just like without things like crypto
uh kind of acting outside of
institutions becomes
too impossible and i don't even
necessarily mean outside of governments
even just you know outside of
corporations like becomes too impossible
and there's just like terrible things
that come as a result
um and if things going in the other
direction like
it obviously is a uh a risk but
you know at the same time i think in the
long term like a crypto can
potentially even like offer defenses as
much as attacks against that sort of
thing
yeah many throughout history many of the
most destructive things came from
centralized institutions versus
uh sort of from the people operating in
the shadows
and you know i've been talking to a
bunch of psychedelics folks
that people doing researchers like greg
doblin uh
in uh johns hopkins there's a lot of
exciting research on psychedelics
and one thing you could say about
operating at the edge of legality
it could actually accelerate the
adoption of particular things like
whether it's marijuana or psychedelics
they can help people out it's almost
accelerates the policy
it forces the policy to catch up to
where the people stand right so there's
a positive way of
doing things that are in the gray area
of legality and creating a market that
allows people to
to uh in a safe way be able to
participate in this gray area
yeah i mean the other thing to keep in
mind of course is that the the set of
like the kinds of things that just like
payment processors as companies try to
restrict people you from
is much larger than the set of things
that's illegal right right like part of
that is because they want to be super
conservative and like the more layers
you have the more they're like
kids conservative because they're scared
of what what what the layer below them
will do to them
um sometimes they have their own you
know moral opinions of various kinds
you know they go after lots of people
right like they make life really hard
for
you know like sex workers for example
look at you know psychedelics as you
mentioned
there's uh like a lot of
activity even including stuff that is
totally legal that just you know there's
this like
you know shadow like paypal credit card
governments or whatever you want to call
it and no no
that makes it just hard to participate
in this stuff so i think like reducing
the number of intermediaries is
definitely
normally a good thing
you